I'm glad to say she now joins me
well welcome
[Laughter]
um I mean that's quite an intro when you
read it all out isn't it yeah and you've
been at the center of this storm and can
I start by apologizing for uh the Tweet
which you liked which entered you into
this Bear Pit of Mayhem let's go back to
that because I read this this tweet from
CNN in which they seem to be going out
of their way to cover a story about a
cervical cancer screening report in
which they were trying not to use the
word woman an individual with a service
and I thought this is preposterous yeah
you're talking about women aren't you
you liked it and then you followed up
and said actually I I just think women
have cervixes yeah absolutely and then
what happened uh and then I got all
kinds of like you said all hell broke
loose I mean I thought it was a good way
a sort of safe way to kind of put my
opinions out there and the opinions of
all of the women that I spoke to all of
the time who were asking someone to say
something about this you like you you
did a tweet and I thought okay I like
that it's just a tentative kind of toe
in the water and it was kind of amusing
what you were saying and you know it was
a stupid issue it was funny it was so
ridiculous like you said and then the
people that started sort of calling from
my beheading you know metaphorically
um
there is that as well but but you know
people calling for me to lose the whip
in the party are all the sort of people
that were running or leading labor
societies and that's where we've got the
problem in the party I think so you get
all this abuse it's so bad you end up
temporarily coming off Twitter because
it was so vile but what is even more
shocking to me is that your own labor
party colleagues from the top down
basically threw you to the walls yeah
they didn't want to go there this is too
toxic yeah they couldn't even say what a
woman is in fact it's against armor your
boss at labor party
um he was asked directly whether a woman
had a penis Ferrari listen to this
well a woman can have a penis
look I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
no no I just is it transphobic to say
only women have a cervix well it is uh
something that uh shouldn't be said it
is not right but Andrew I don't think
that the rosie Duffield should not have
said that can you explain to people
watching why she should not have said
that Andrew I don't think that
um we can just go through various things
that people said
I found it extraordinary I mean I like
hairstyle I get on very well with fellow
Arsenal fans it's a good time to be an
Arsenal fan I gotta say on this he's
really LED himself and the party down
because you've got to be able to say
what a woman is if you want to lead a
political party absolutely it's not
difficult it's an adult female but more
people in this country are women and
women will knock on doors campaign
donate to parties and vote and if women
don't feel that we're represented that's
a serious State of Affairs politically
and I had met with Keir I think the aide
who talked about me so that I was always
always in that of his office I met with
him once well Matthew Doyle
all the time yeah I met him once I mean
let's actually play The Clue this was
leaked by Guido Forks the media website
let's listen to what he actually said
Matthew door
foreign
[Music]
on behalf of Kia stama and there he is
actively briefing against you as it
turns out lying about the number of
times you've seen kirstan he said you're
in and out all the time and mocking you
for not spending enough time in your
Canterbury constituency saying you're
spending too much time with JK Rowling
yeah I mean I've never met this man I I
have no idea how he thinks he knows
those things and how many times have you
been in kirst Armor's office I was there
the week before he gave that interview
to Andrew Ma and I was trying to explain
my point of view I was trying to explain
that lots of women's groups were in
touch with me that I had had nearly 400
Bunches of flowers and cards and emails
and they never stopped they haven't I've
not met a woman
who would disagree with you I've not met
one I don't know where they exist these
people yeah but I have not met a woman
and I've traveled far and wide in the
last two years I've not met a single
woman who looks me in the eye privately
and says well it's all ridiculous of
course we know what a woman there are a
few labor MPS there are a few right I
know they exist because I see the hell
that you have to go through but just to
be clear on Kia Starman how many times
have you been in his office since then
uh not once not once no so this is
complete nonsense being skewed too I
mean but this guy doesn't know me
doesn't know anything about me but it's
a very clever line isn't it I I knew I'd
heard that they've been briefing about
me before this but of course I had no
proof it was just this kind of feeling
that you know I knew that they weren't
pleased with my stance on things but to
hear him I mean that's so clever to
start sowing the seeds of Doubt oh maybe
she's not in her constituency and then
it gets through to my what's the truth
about that of course I'm there every
single week like every other MP you know
I live there I've lived there since 19.
how many times have you seen Jay care
running personally in the last two years
I saw at Christmas so the Famous Lunch
yeah that was another look that was
we've seen her a couple of times yeah
and we talk most days actually you're
not spending most weekends up in
Scotland plotting that would be lovely
but no I'm at home in Canterbury and
we're going to come to her in a moment
on kirstama though when you when you saw
him what did you say to him
um I just explained in the situation I
said I'm so sorry the story at the time
was that I wasn't going to conference
because of all the death threats I was
so embarrassed by that story getting out
there I hadn't said I hadn't announced I
wasn't going to I told a couple of
friends that I thought it was a good
idea not to go it was his first big
speech I didn't want to be the headline
ironically I was the headline for about
three weeks about that and uh so I said
to him you know we've got into this
situation will you meet with these
groups will you hear what I've got to
say and he was really sympathetic he
said oh I haven't heard of this group
labor women's declaration 8 000
signatures to say that they want this to
be discussed they want people to to talk
about it freely and since then a couple
of conferences have passed and labor
women's declaration are not even allowed
to have a stall at neighborhood and then
you know a few days ago we see you being
openly mocked and jeered by your own
side in the comments yeah for standing
up for women's safety I mean Ben
Bradshaw was one and who was the other
it was another male right yeah this is
the see a little bit of this
the bill clearly conflicts with the
equality act and would have
repercussions for women for women across
the UK and given the previous uq does he
not understand how vitally important
this is at the moment
quite extremely two male labor MPS yeah
Lloyd Russell Moyle and Ben Bradshaw a
former Minister he was heard shouting
absolute rubbish yeah as you defended
the need for spaces segregated by sex
yeah how have we got to misplace Rosie
where what seems to me to be just the
obvious Common Sense thing to do is
being eradicated at the altar of
political correctness I think it's
activists I think it's the kind of
people if you are based in London and
you're leading a party where you know
your staff and all your associations and
labor societies are the same kind of
people we're very nepotistic party I'm
finding out I guess the others are as
well I don't I can't speak on that but
you're surrounded by the same people the
same activists the same people are on
the NEC or the boards of this that and
the other you're just hearing the same
voice when you see the leader of the
party securest armor unable to say
whether people with penises are women
what was your reaction I
I speechless really I mean
it didn't I don't know what to make of
it half the time it sort of seems funny
half the time it's really scary high
profile women Dame Joan Collins was one
a great friend of mine who didn't want
to say what she thought a woman was
anymore because didn't want to get the
aggro that would come from answering the
question that's where we've got to where
some of those glamorous women of all
time like Joan just feel that they've
been cowed by the mob really sad and
they don't want to go into that Bear Pit
that you've gone into you know how vile
it can be but I have to because I have
hundreds of thousands of women
contacting me and I'm involved in lots
of women's groups and I know how they
feel and I think with a party of Working
Class People and working-class women
those are Our Roots the kind of people
that are likely to be in the kind of
prison that you talked about at the
start of the show a working class women
that's our job and I will continue I
mean that story of the of the man who
raped two women yeah and tonight his
ex-wife or her ex-wife has now broken
her silence and apparently says she she
thinks he's scamming everybody is a man
just using this as an excuse to get into
women's prison which is why his rights
as a rapist are something we're talking
about anyway right you know that is
absolutely great let's take a short
break Rosie after the break I want to
talk about your friend JK Rowling is who
tweeted this Rosie Duffield an
ex-assistant teacher single mother
survivor of domestic abuse one labor a
seat they thought was unwinnable post
Corbin she was returned upon an
increased majority and this is how labor
repays her
my special guest Rosie duffel
your friendship with JK Rowling I mean
you're joined I guess by this issue in a
sense that she she was very supportive
of you publicly because she could see
the hell you were going through she's
gone through similar stuff for
expressing similar views of trying to
support women's rights to safety and and
so on
tell me about JK and your friendship
um she's my
she's very very funny we all kind of
we've got to sort of you know
groups we've got
a DM groups
we want to kind of keep each other going
really on a daily basis people like
Julie bindle and me well there's a funny
picture actually because I think you and
Julie Bendel uh you were with her and
you wore a t-shirt with you and Jake
here running as dinosaurs after David
Lammy yeah Labor uh Shadow Minister
called turfs dinosaurs that was the gift
that really kept on giving and because
you know I've been sent dinosaur jewelry
dinosaur chocolate
it's what do you well I mean what the
wave labor party have responded
it seems to me they're siding with
people who are waging an Insidious war
against women's rights so what does it
say about them from secure downwards I
think it is fear I think all of it is
fear yeah I think the fact that we've
got so many very senior men so the
Chiefs of Staff the general secretary
Kia himself you know all this head of
comms or whatever it is he does they're
all men they're all men based in London
I don't think that they're listening to
people I don't think they're hearing
people what's your message to kirst
armor tonight if he's watching this I
think I'd like him to to listen to
women's groups I'd like to to know that
he's met with those people that are
really concerned about should he should
he listen to you I mean should you not
that would be nice if you want to have a
definition of a woman are you the person
you should go to could you help him with
that I'm a particular expert in that but
it would be nice too you know what a
woman is because you are what I thought
I did yeah it'd be nice if we just had a
dialogue you know he's my colleague and
we're we're there and one of the pledges
he told us when he was signing for
leadership was as someone who'd employed
thousands of people his door was always
open and
you know be nice if we could just just
go in have you tried to see him again
um I've messaged him a few times and
when I've had particularly terrible
abuse it got really really bad about a
year or so ago and he did phone me and
say he was sorry but I think he feels
very limited as to what he can do he
won't for example show public support he
or why uh I guess all of the pressure
from all of the labor student groups and
the labor activists and most of them are
but do you think he believes it himself
I've got no idea he's never given you
any indication no I don't know I don't
know what he thinks really
you're in a place where the labor party
look should be roaring to a pretty
comfortable beach in the next election
but this women's issue isn't going away
it's kind of ripping large parts of the
party apart in many ways yeah and I
don't want that of course I don't want
that but in 2019 I remember telling a
few people possibly care I don't know
but in 2019 there were two things on the
Dual step for me in Canterbury for exit
Jeremy corbyn and anti-Semitism in the
same sentence and it was very hard to to
win as an MP in 2019 as a labor MP as
you know the third thing that came up
was women taking me aside and asking to
tell me about their experiences one was
a social worker one was a teacher one
was just a mum and it was before way
before your Tweet before I said anything
in public and I took them aside and I
listened to them so I knew this is not
going away but when I tried to mention
it I was told to colleagues even I was
told it was a niche issue shouldn't be
talking about it we should be talking
about important things and big issues
when you saw for example I mean it seems
to me there's a lot of fronts the attack
is coming from at the moment the Brit
Awards with the gender neutrality issue
which many people like me warned at the
time would almost certainly lead to the
awards actually being skewed more to the
men we'd have the opposite effect to
what people thought it would have when
you saw all the male artists nominees
were men this year what did you think
it's pretty depressing isn't it I mean
you know lots of us were talking the
women who haven't talked about the
gender critical side of things and and
the trans side of things are all really
angry about that but you know that's the
face of all of this if you change our
language if we don't get to protect our
spaces this is kind of where we're going
but if we don't take the word woman and
we don't celebrate Womanhood and we
don't celebrate femininity and being
female what's wrong with a best female
artist category if the trans Lobby group
wanted an award show have their own or
have their own category yeah I don't
mind if you know Sam Smith in one minute
he's a straight guy next minute he's a
gay guy next minute he wants us to call
him they them because he's non-binary I
don't give a damn what he wants to call
himself I do give a damn one his
campaigning means the brittle walls
decides to go gender-neutral and the
victims are women artists who've now
been completely evaporated for this
event it's a gender-neutral usually
means without women or women being
excluded seen those signs of the news
that are tweeted and there's a disabled
sign and a woman's sign and a unisex
sign and then there's another door and
it's just got a man sign you think hang
on a sec and then you get to sport which
is even more depressing because
everybody knows how ridiculously unfair
this is everybody knows that just
reducing testosterone doesn't make any
difference post-puberty to a man's body
mass his muscle his strength his lung
capacity I interviewed one of the
British champion shot putter last night
uh Amelia strickler and she was you know
really good actually we've got a little
clip I think of it from the interview
last night
I think we've got a clip of the
interview but she was great because she
she basically said look we're we're
going to end up I've got a hair now
they'll never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes female it's
a real issue even you know Dino this
summer said you know I've had lady
issues and she didn't perform well when
she didn't perform well that day and you
know it's understandable
I mean I hadn't even really thought
about that aspect of it but she's so
right is that trans women athletes don't
have that issue of a monthly period that
they have to deal with as athletes which
can be very debilitating if not
performance reducing as we just heard
um again no thought given to this other
than we're going to get our way and we
don't care about women's rights here or
fairness and equality in their own
Stampede for what they see is fairness
and equality for their own Community the
trans Community they are creating a new
unfairness inequality absolutely My
friend Sharon Davis yeah I've spent a
lot of time
she's fantastic and she feels I think
I'm not putting words in her mouth I've
been to events where she's spoken that
what you know she missed out on a gold
medal partly because of the doping of
some of the Eastern European countries I
think she feels that she's reliving that
all over it we saw it with the New
Zealand weightlift female weightlifting
team where Laurel Hubbard who had
competed as a man before now got an
Olympic plays at the expense of a woman
born to a female body yeah that to me is
completely unfair Laurel Hubbard was
unsuccessful as a male competitor and
then suddenly as an Olympian yeah as a
woman and we've seen it in cycling well
there's a cricketer down in kentouch
it's six foot four inch cricketer who
was a male cricketer with an average of
17 I think becomes a female female
cricketer and suddenly averages 120. wow
I was a cricket fan I find that utterly
ridiculous yeah I mean it's just not
fair like you said it's not a level
playing but if you say that you're a
trans foam apparently no I mean we've
talked in sports and circles you know I
know some sports psychologists who who
are really talking about this issue and
what about different categories because
this argument is in its infancy we
haven't got there yet we haven't found
Solutions but the solution isn't pushing
women aside it can't be or abusing women
or threatening women I mean these scenes
we saw at the protest about the Scottish
gender recognition bill which to me is a
ridiculous bill which allows 16 year
olds they're not allowed to buy a drink
legally now determine their lifetime
gender uh without any need for any
medical diagnosis I think it's crazy but
people were protesting about the UK
government protesting rightly about
what's going on up there and they were
actually having signs saying decapitate
to us you've been named sort of Chief
Turf along with JK Rowling these people
wanted and they're trans activist wanted
you and JK running and people like you
to be decapitated yeah yeah what do you
feel about that
um it sounds weird but I'm sort of used
to it I mean all women MPS get them you
shouldn't be used to it no it's
disgusting I shouldn't really but but
it's really kind of normal actually yeah
yeah look I know it's been horrific for
you I can only apologize again for
starting all this because without my
tweet which you liked you might have
been blissfully carrying on as a below
the radar MP
I suspect you would have spoke about at
some stage but I think you're very gutsy
for what you do I think you should keep
going don't bow to the Mob We need more
people like you and JK Rowling and
Amelia strickler and people like this to
speak out on behalf of women women need
to speak out to save women's rights and
men need to do the same yeah thank you
good to see you you too keep fighting
thank you and a secure style is watching
my invitation for you to come on the
program remains maybe tomorrow's the key
come and answer this charge I'll tell
you what a woman isn't a woman doesn't
have a penis it's really not that hard
it's a kid you want to run the country
you better get with the program and it's
a program it's been around thousands of
years